it's great to be joined today by Tom
Shelton who's the religion and belief
correspondent for NPR news also author
of the book a nation of nations a great
American immigration story Tom it's so
great to have you and there's so many
different places we could start given
the discussion that's taking place right
now around immigration policy maybe one
place to start is as someone who's been
covering this for for some time is what
we are seeing right now a sort of new
era in attitudes towards immigration
that we're seeing from the current
administration or is it actually going
back to something we've seen before in a
sense well yes and no David I mean it's
immediately reminiscent of a debate that
we had just over fifty years ago at the
time of the passage of the 1965
Immigration Act when we really had to
decide and did decide what kind of
immigration we wanted for this country
but in a sense it even goes back all the
way to the beginning of our republic the
you know the interesting thing is that
the United States is almost unique among
the countries of the world in that most
countries come into being with the
people already there on the land so they
don't really have to decide you know
what kind of country they're going to be
in terms of the culture in terms of the
country as a nation the United States
was formed really as a new nation and
people were coming from different areas
and so there was this question from the
beginning this idea at the beginning
that we could be a universal nation I
mean George Washington famously said the
bosom of America is open to receive not
only the opulent and respectable
stranger but the oppressed and
persecuted of all nations and religions
now that was the ideal that was the
aspiration but it was counteracted in a
sense by the reality of prejudice which
was there from the beginning and it was
really only in 1965 that we were able to
reconcile this aspiration of our country
as a universal nation with the reality
that for most of the first 200 years of
our settle
we were prejudiced against immigrants of
color immigrants from really anywhere
other than northwest Europe and finally
in 1965 we had a new immigration act
that clearly opened America's doors for
the first time in an official way to
immigrants of color now there was a lot
of debate around whether that was a
right thing to do or not and it's in a
sense we are now revisiting that debate
50 some years later yes so you mentioned
the 65 law which which up until then you
we had a circumstance or situation of
quotas to allocate immigrant visas based
on countries of origin when we hear
things like we've got to figure out
what's going on with Muslim immigration
or we're taking Syrian immigration off
of the table or we would prefer people
from Norway rather than Haiti or
whatever other countries that in a sense
seems reminiscent of this kind of
prioritization or tears of people that
is a pre-1965
sort of circumstances that right exactly
right David and it's really interesting
to me because you know it's almost
word-for-word in many ways the debate
that we had in Congress in 1965 around
the decision of whether to do away with
national origin quarters you might think
that that debate was left behind but
strangely you know we're hearing some of
the very same words I mean if you go
back to that 1965 debate you had members
of Congress saying we really don't want
immigrants from Africa
we don't want immigrants from Asia we
want that's not part of what America is
that's not our heritage or a culture and
you know those arguments were
definitively rejected in the context of
the civil rights movement the 1965
Immigration Act passed by a by a large
margin and yet here we are in 2019 2018
hearing some of those very same
arguments I mean when when President
Trump said that we don't want as you
suggested we don't want immigrants from
[ __ ] countries that was very close
to what opponents of the 65 Immigration
Act was
saying at that time I'd love to get your
thoughts on the kind of push that the
talking point push-pull that we're
seeing on this issue among some where
you hear of the perspective that as
you're pointing out empirically this is
a nation of immigrants and then the
opposition says well yes but things have
changed because now we have an
established country we're not in this
kind of manifest destiny early phase and
then the other side comes back and says
we'll hold on a second
if you think back to when when the the
immigration from Europe was happening we
were seeing a sort of ranking of
immigrants Irish were considered others
Italians typically from the south of
Italy were considered others now they
are part of the in-crowd and it's a new
group that is sort of being are
authorized and marginalized is there
actually an empirical difference that we
can draw or is it sort of a repetition
of that same attitude well the original
bias was in favor of immigrants as you
suggest from Northwest Europe and
towards the end of the 19th century when
we saw a surge of immigrant populations
from Mediterranean countries and from
Eastern Europe Slavic countries
including Jews there was a lot of
opposition to that at that time there
really wasn't much of a anticipation of
immigration from outside outside Europe
altogether so that wasn't at that time a
huge issue you know it's just what's
happened after in the aftermath of the
1965 Immigration Act you'd want to look
at data in 1960 seven out of eight
immigrants were coming from Europe to
include southern Eastern Europe but from
Europe seven out of eight immigrants
after the passage of the 1965 Act in
2009 out of 10 immigrants to the United
States were coming from outside Europe
so in that in that thirty five year
period a total and dramatic
transformation in the character of our
immigrant population and that sort of
set the stage for this debate that we're
having now a real kind of
anxiety and the part of some Americans
that you know that our heritage is is
really changing now you mentioned
something interesting that I think is
important to point out throughout most
of our history there hasn't really been
much debate around this notion that we
are a nation of immigrants now we are
actually seeing a debate about that
there are voices on that largely on
their right who are saying you know
we're not really a nation of immigrants
who are a nation of settlers and they're
distinguished distinguishing between
immigrants and settlers or pioneers in
the sense that settlers and pioneers
built the country and then immigrants
seen the United States already built
already powerful already prosperous
wanted to come in and take advantage of
that and so there's this distinction
between immigrants and settlers which is
something that what I never came across
that ever before in the history of our
country yes so like as a correspondent
who covers this stuff when you hear that
brought up you've not heard this
distinction before between settlers and
immigrants and now we're hearing it or
with any of the other distinctions that
are being made yes immigration before
was is different than immigration now or
any of these distinction
how can you examine on as close to an
objective basis as possible whether what
underlies that is or maybe racism or
xenophobia as some suggest or whether
the defense that no we're talking here
about a country that has limited
resources and at a certain point
decisions have to be made about who gets
to come in or who doesn't or the idea of
losing status or the driving down of
wages as the talking point goes how can
you as a reporter say okay I'm hearing
the assertion let's now examine what
really is underlying it that's a really
astute question David and I would say
that the the important change or the
distinction to be made is between those
who are nervous about the numbers of
immigrants coming in and fearing
therefore that you know the sheer
quantity of immigration could jeopardize
you know job prospects for Nate
born Americans that is one concern
that's a concern about numbers and then
there is a concern about culture which
really has nothing to do with the
numbers of immigrants coming in it has
to do with the kind of immigrants who
are coming in that's a very different
argument though those are the arguments
that emphasize sort of a threat to our
our heritage our Western traditions our
civilization it's a it's a it's an
argument about identity about culture I
think those are two very different
arguments the the first one I think you
would have a hard time arguing that that
is essentially a racist argument it's a
kind of a economic argument it can be
debated both ways the second one because
it emphasizes cultural differences I
think that's a lot more problematic are
the lines clear in your mind in terms of
the parties the two major parties and
this issue and to add some context to
that the discussion around the shutdown
in the wall is mostly dividing among
party lines so you have people on the
Left who tend to be against the wall and
people on the right who all else being
equal are generally more in favor of the
wall proposed by the president but if
you look a little bit wider like the
last 30 years you had a Republican in
Ronald Reagan who was granted some
degree of amnesty through to Trump who
wants to build this wall and is talking
about [ __ ] countries even on the
Democratic side you had deportation
records set by President Barack Obama
and now this push towards some in some
areas sanctuary cities and opposition to
the wall so to get back to the question
are the lines as clear as they might
seem in terms of party and this issue
they've really changed David there is a
and a strong argument to be made that
the US economy depends on immigrant
labor that immigrants actually
particularly now with a relatively low
unemployment that there's a real demand
for immigrant labor and if you look sort
of traditionally at the arguments around
the debater
immigration you have groups like the US
Chamber of Commerce that has
traditionally taken a pretty Pro
immigration point of view and you know
libertarian groups Cato Institute is
very much Pro immigrant and the
traditional Republican ideology has been
much more aligned with these economic
arguments from business groups like the
Chamber of Commerce and sort of seeing
the contribution that immigrant
immigrant labor makes to the economy as
the Republican Party has moved in a more
sort of ideological direction to
emphasize cultural issues you really see
a change in that regard there's also
been a change on the Democratic side you
know back in the in the early eighties
that say during the presidency of Ronald
Reagan the Democratic Party was was
pretty strongly influenced by organized
labor organized labor at that time labor
unions were largely representing white
workers and there was a lot of anxiety
among the labor movement about
immigration and you had some pretty
prominent Democratic leaders back then
that were very made very clear their
their nervousness about immigrant labor
I mean people like Eugene McCarthy or
the congresswoman from Texas Barbara
Jordan had a lot of concern about
immigrant labor for fear of the impact
it would have on particularly African
American workers and now you know as the
economy has changed the Democratic Party
represents a lot more workers of color
you don't see that argument be made the
sort of the nervousness about
immigration you don't see that at all in
the Democratic Party anymore and
conversely in the Republican side you
see very few voices who are sort of
making the traditional pro-immigrant
argument that we associated with the
business lobby in the past along these
partisan lines the last thing I wanted
to touch on was this issue of the
corporations that benefit from hiring
undocumented immigrants that has been
effectively missing from the discussion
obviously the president lobbying for his
wall is going to scapegoat undocumented
immigrants as the ones responsible for
holding down wages but you don't read
here a serious critique from either side
about the reality that it's the
corporations that are basically going
unpunished for hiring undocumented labor
that are really the driving force
between a behind a lot of that hiring
and wages is there just no political
appetite to to open up that can of worms
okay that's an interesting point you
know there is this idea of Eve Arif I
that would sort of require employers to
verify the immigrant status of workers
that they hire sort of electronically
against the database yeah the business
community has been notable notably
reticent about that Democrats you know
have been somewhat cool to that as well
as a result it really hasn't gotten very
far and you know it's a little hard for
me to sort of probe exactly why that is
we do know this that the structure of
our economy has changed dramatically in
the last 50 years we've seen a huge
growth in the service sector and
particularly in those parts of the
service sector that that do depend on
low skilled labor whether it's whether
its yard work you know lawn servicing
and landscape whether it's restaurant
the kind of service workers in
restaurants whether it's you know
construction I mean they're the demand
for unskilled labor the kinds of jobs
that immigrants are primed to fill has
really grown a lot and that may be why
you know you're not seeing a lot of
corporations or businesses right now
leading the charge against undocumented
workers because you know they are
employing them no question about it
we've been speaking with Tom Shelton
who's the religion and belief
correspondent for NPR news we're linking
to his book a nation of Nations a great
American immigration to a story Tom
thank you so much for talking to me it's
been really interesting thank you David